will reject high of erdogan win another
term the Turkish leader has got a much
needed endorsement from a nationalist
party leader but will that make a
difference in Sunday's runoff and what
impact will it have on turkey's future
this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
Muhammad an entire era of Turkish
politics has been defined by President
reject erdogan his Challenger kamalu is
his polar opposite both in personality
and politics but as we reach Sunday's
closely font runoff election both
candidates are now turning to
nationalist groups to widen their base
the struggling economy inflation and the
devastating aftermath of February's
earthquakes are all pressing issues but
it appears nationalism could be a
defining factor in this election we'll
explore that and other issues with our
guests in a moment but first this report
by cancio Lopez joseon
foreign
with just a few days left before
Sunday's runoff election Turkish
president regist erdogan appears
confident he'll score another win
to increase his chances he's turned to
Hardline nationalists like Cena and Owen
the third place candidate didn't make it
to the next round of voting but with a
tight race ahead his supporters could
shift the balance
I invite all voters who backed this in
the first round to now support Mr
erdogan in the runoff election
the opposition is feeling the pressure
and is also looking to nationalist
groups for support
has adopted a more strident tone in
recent weeks embracing an anti-immigrant
rhetoric it's a risk that could alienate
many Kurds who supported him in the
first round of voting
I'm addressing everybody out there we
did not find our homeland on the street
we will not leave our homeland to this
mentality that allowed 10 million
irregular migrants to come amongst us
analysts suggest the opposition
underestimated voter's sense of
nationalism some may criticize president
erdogan's policies but many see him as a
strong leader he's the individual eye
Harry Potter one gets 55 60 even 70 I
love him what more can this man do for
this country unfortunately we have so
many ungrateful people
some of the president's critics say he
is not a Democratic leader
a lot has changed since the last
presidential election in 2018 our
freedom is limited we're prevented from
expressing ourselves erdogan's ties with
Russian President Vladimir Putin makes
many Western governments uneasy along
with the rising influence of the Turkish
military across the region but many of
his supporters appear to welcome it
with both candidates turning towards
nationalist groups to win some question
what effect this will have on how turkey
is governed in the next five years
for Inside Story
[Music]
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests they're all joining us from
Turkey in Istanbul mehmed editorial
coordinator at the daily Sabah newspaper
in
the vice chairman of the opposition
democracy and progress party
and also in Istanbul Tariq osloo
professor of international relations and
the dean of the faculty of Science and
Arts at Istanbul Aiden University a warm
welcome to you all and thanks so much
for joining us today on Inside Story
Tariq let me start with you today
um how much has nationalism turned out
to be a defining factor in this election
cycle I think that's the key issue of
this process because in the first half
of the election is we all of us remember
quite clearly erdogan the equivalent
president has used this ideology quite
efficient and successfully whereas on
the other hand was somehow quite big on
this point so he pursued a very much
polite and Economy based strategy but at
the end of the day we had seen the
results supporting the extreme
nationalist discourse adopted by arduan
their Sparkle on the way to the runoff
has shifted the approach to a further
nation that is him and very much talking
about the idea that if I come to the
presidency I guarantee that the survival
of the state will be issued I will deal
with the problem of immigration
successfully and turkey will improve all
kind of problems it has encountered in
recent years so nationalism as the
political ideology has become very much
adopted by commissioner only himself so
it was already the case that everyone
has proved that he's a master politician
in terms of using nationalist ideology
in this particle is chance but the core
issue in this runoff process concerns
the immigration issue the fact that
Kalisto Rollo had to secure the support
of USDA amid USDA one of the leaders of
the party is supporting the Coalition
shifting its support to conditioner
always speaks for itself it means that
with USDA in the nation allies I will be
in a much better position to deal with
problem of immigration and so you can
count on me that was the message
has been given Tarik I'll get back to
you a little bit later about what you
were addressing with regards to kamalu
and the fact that he's Allied himself
with nationalist figures at this point
but but first I want to ask you about
the fact that the Nationalist Hardline
candidate sinan Owen he had received a
surprising 5.2 percent of the votes in
the first round and he has now endorsed
president erdogan do you believe that
his voters are going to follow his lead
and give his votes to erdogan give their
votes to erdogan I think it's an
open-ended question none of us is in a
position to say that it is hundred
percent sure that supporters of argon
will shift uh to support this office
was saying that there is something wrong
with erdogan's policies so I am
contenting uh I I'm a competitor in this
particular election and we could not
forget the fact that one has been
supported by other parties in the attire
lives so and you should not think a lot
uh is the only guy who used to represent
uh the Wolves his allies had already
said here you should also put them in
the context with his struggle with
Ursula as well so one important guy is
the shifting towards uh commissioner and
the other important guys you know what
shifting towards the president Arbonne
has has made everything much more
complicated than it used to be so we are
not in a position to say that all of uh
synonyms
president erdogan
Amendment at a time when
sinan Owen has been called by many
analysts potentially a king maker in the
election cycle I want to ask you get
your perspective about if you believe
that that Owen has the kind of powerful
party apparatus behind him that would
enable him to ensure that his voters or
those who voted for him support erdogan
rather than skip the runoff
well I I agree with uh with the previous
speaker that you know Mr Owens voting
potential is not similar to other
candidates where they can actually lead
that lead a mass and direct them to a
certain direction on who to who to
support I think it you know his his
voter base is very heterogeneous genius
and it's not homogeneous in the sense
that there is no there he doesn't even
represent a party in in that sense so it
is very difficult to see where his
voting will will be directed to his
voter base will be directed to
um on the on the on the case of
nationalism I think we have to
differentiate between nationalism and we
understand it also in the west or in
Europe versus the new Ultra nationalist
Tendencies On The Rise particularly due
to rise of I mean due to the presence of
Syrian refugees
for the past decade so I think
classifying president erdogan or Mr
erdogan as as in this leader that has
been capitalizing on very
ultra-nationalistic policies I think
would be a misunder I think
misrepresentation of his voter base to
begin with and also I think we should
differentiate between his nationalism
which I think it's very reactionary it's
a it's a it's a patriotism in in the
face of threat security threats for
example or the Western dictation on on
Turkish policies versus the ultra
nationalism which has been the case with
this election which both Mr erdogan and
Mr Kalisto have been trying to appeal to
I think the king maker whether that's
c901 or whether it is these reactionary
or Ultra Nationals votes it's something
that we have to perhaps discuss and
debate and and clarify so
If he if he's a king maker that will be
something that we have to answer by
answering whether he's it has the
ability to direct all his voter base or
that five an odd percentage towards one
candidate or not I'm not sure if he has
that ability and he himself also says
that he's not 100 sure whether his all
his voters will be directed towards uh
either candidate if he was to align with
one of them
let me just follow up on something
you're saying you're talking about
trying to differentiate I believe you
were saying between nationalism and
alternationalism and I'm I'm trying to
understand precisely how you're
delineating this as well because if you
have both of the major candidates if you
have President erdogan and you have
Kamal Khalid that are both
allying themselves with figures of the
ultra nationalist parties you know who
are taking anti-migration and
anti-refugee stances where does that put
them along the Spectrum going into the
second round look the the anti-refugee
or anti-migrant Tendencies has been very
loud in the Turkish media in the Turkish
politics although we have to underline
that this is not the general sentiment
of the Turkish society and I'm making a
differentiation between the ultra
nationalists which have been you know
which have been described as king maker
in this election and the Patriotic
citizens or voter base which both Mr
kusharlo and Mr erdogan has in their
voter base so there has to be that
differentiation but I think more crucial
is that and the reason why this old
neutral Ultra nationalist Tendencies
have been the king maker is that they
both don't align themselves with both Mr
klister or Mr Mr erdogan and in the
system where 50 plus one or every vote
counts every segment of the society
becomes very crucial hence why Mr
kushtoro for example is has was was able
to attract the voters of the of the the
Kurds or the hdp and at the same time an
ultra nationalist like Mr umizoza on his
side I think both Mr Kalisto and Mr
erdogan is trying to Target every single
vote in this new system that is which is
50 plus one becomes very very crucial to
have and and now that it is in you know
for both Mr cholesterol and Mr erdogan
there is this fine line where whether
their voters will go to ballot boxes in
the second round one for Mr erdogan I
think there is this sense of success
being you know the number one Alliance
and the Parliament and the foreign
which could perhaps lead to their voter
base not to the go to The Ballot Box and
I think the those those voters are the
king makers rather than some of the
marginal or or some of this new Ultra
nationalist tendencies
let's go back almost two weeks uh let's
take a look at the lead up to the first
round I want to ask you from your
perspective did the opposition
underestimate how much of a role
nationalism would play in this election
and voters sense of nationalism as well
I wouldn't call it nationalism I would
call the effect of the third candidate
Mr Mr Cylon obviously made a made a
difference and I think the participation
also was a bit surprising because the
Delta between Mr erdogan and Mr
cholesterol is 2.5 million volts whereas
over 8 million people did not vote so if
you think about it if we step back
almost 12 million people did not vote
for neither either Mr cholesterol
whereas the Delta is 2.5 million so
there's almost five five times as many
people as the Delta is missing in about
practice foreign
so I think the focus on both sides over
the last two weeks has been those words
either by luring Mr on himself or his
Waters or by during the victory party
and Mr ozda which supported Iran in the
first round or mobilizing the waters so
I think that's the math rather than the
nationalism I agree with the previous
speakers in a sense that this is a
typical marginal water Theory situation
the two candidates are close to 50 but
not quite and the missing water or the
marginal water is believed to be
represented by the nationalist movements
so therefore they are catering towards
those it doesn't mean that there's a
general tilt towards the nationalistic
movements because if you think about the
parties who are branded as National
sparkies right there used to be two in
the previous election e and MHP and
there's three now right e MHP and
victory party their total what was
around 20 21 and now it's around 20 223
so there's a notch up but certainly not
a massive Grassroots movement right that
two percent increase so I think it's
more of a marginal water Theory Behavior
rather than nationalism supply all right
let me ask you this uh the fact of the
matter is that uh kamalakly cerolu has
really changed his tone in recent weeks
I mean he had cultivated this very sort
of grandfatherly image you know and uh
he stepped up his anti-migrant his
anti-refugee rhetoric you you yourself
talked about the endorsement from the
victory party
um doesn't this risk alienating perhaps
a substantial part of his base
especially many Kurds who supported him
in the first round I mean that was that
could have been a potentialist but it
did not materialize if you look at the
Declaration by various people they are
still in those Mr cholesterol I mean in
the grandfather image or the unifying
leader was the Right image in a sense
that he is the candidate for a very
broad Coalition right they bringing
together various parties various
movements Under the Tent so that's
almost a natural extension of his
personality of his political character
as well as the realities he's
represented right leading or
representing a broader line so that's
almost inevitable whereas in the second
round he's stressing his security
credentials and the anti-immigrant term
for two reasons one the current
government attacked him on those fronts
uh sometimes doctoring images sometimes
making allegations right so I think he's
underscoring those credentials uh as
anti-terrorism strong National Security
leadership so I think that's one and two
is as I described the margin of water is
there so it's pragmatically he
cultivating that particular segment just
like the president himself is doing by
cultivating Mr wrong so I think that's
all being understood by various Waters
so there may be some marginal reactions
but I think the broader water base like
for 45 which is his basic water base in
the first one first round it's
understanding what he's doing so I don't
expect this in
no matter who ends up prevailing in the
runoff will the strong performance of
the nationalists in these elections pull
the Turkish government policy
further to the right in the years to
come do you think that will be the
impact of this if you are asking this
question in the context of how Turkish
foreign policy might evolve in the used
to come I can 400 percent say that don't
even come much closer to the
non-vestment countries such as China and
Russia and which also includes other
non-western powers as well this also
suggests that the leaders who have
adopted somehow illegal and
authoritarian tendencies in domestic
politics will become much more visible
around the globe and this will somehow
boost the chances of such kind of
leaders to maintain the power or to come
to power in the elections in their own
countries in the years to come and also
we can also suggest that if everyone
wins this election a nationalism has a
political ideology will continue to
dominate Turkish foreign
to some extent to some degree but we
should not forget the fact that Norman
uh no matter which political uh rivals
or contenders with this election the
most important question facing the
Turkish Nation they used to call will be
how we get rid of this economic crisis
and how turkey improves somehow its
relations with Western Powers it is
foreign policy so a leader who speaks
very much importance about finding a
solution to the economic problem and
also putting Turkish foreign policy in
the context of much better relations
with traditional Western allies
uh will be quite successful these are
the key issues facing the winner of the
presidential election and I I think let
me also say something about the question
you had already put to other speakers
may I say something about that
I think the cholesterol has used a
polarization strategy on the way to the
runoff this was quite the opposite of
the strategy he adopted on the way to
the first round of actions he was
speaking so politely and very much
undervaluing the importance of
economical campaign but the results have
a disproven uh commissioner order so if
he had to change his position I should
also underline another thing he has been
always saying that this is the kind of
election
suggests a kind of referendum on the
future of turkey so he was saying that
we represent the forces of goods whereas
represents the forces of uh bad ugly
forces and also this is a very much
polarizing polarization based strategy
the antithesis of his strategy he
adopted in the past this is also quite
important that it might pay some
dividends in the upcoming elections and
finally let me also say another three
cholesterol have in recent days
participated in one of YouTube shows
bobalatv which was the name of the
YouTube channel and he received
questions from Die Hard Ergo and support
this and he responded to such questions
in the extreme the mic manner taking a
consciously the Constitution even
admitted I did something bad I did
something wrong in the past but if you
give me the chance I prove that I I
learned my lessons so I will become the
president of the whole nation
anyways might face some positive
dividends in in its elections let's see
Amendment whether we want to Define some
of these figures as nationalist or Ultra
nationalist fact of the matter is there
have been new alliances forged by
president erdogan with figures who are
hard-line figures on the right many of
them
anti-migration anti-refugee figures I
want to ask you about the new alliances
that have been made and how that
realigns Turkish politics going forward
if president erdogan prevails in the
runoff how much does that impact the
political landscape in Turkey going
forward well it is no secret that there
is a new turkey and that has been
redeveloped and then there is a new tool
here that has become a big influential
actor in in its region and also
International Community International
politics and I think with this new two
gear it's internal Dynamics have also
changed and I think one of the reasons I
mean this whole political Spectrum or
this new as you call you know this
nationalism or new alliances around
nationalism have shaped is the fact that
there is a huge burden of refugees some
five million refugees in Turkey which
has shaped its contributed shaping its a
domestic politics in one way or the
other and now it has shaped its economy
in one way or the other but with this
new turkey in its region and a new power
uh globally for example when it comes to
its defense industry for that has been
very popular in recent years its
political Dynamics have also changed so
there is you know this new sense of new
turkey that has shaped political uh
psyche of the society that uh you know
created new alliances new movements new
parties a new sense of unity uh in the
face of some of external threats be it
is along its Southern border or with
Syria in Northern Syria or be it in the
East Med for example where turkey has to
protect it its interests or be it in
Libya so there's these new dynamics that
are affected by economy by social issues
like Refugee issue or by security issues
that internal dynamics of I mean
internal politics have been using and
utilizing as an instrument to form these
alliances and how these will clay out in
the future I I think will also depend on
this maintaining this new tool here
whether 2K is going to be you know one
that it becomes the mayor puppet of the
west or turns its back to the east or
puts all its its eggs in one basket or
whether it is going to diversify its
eggs and and partners and you know
on the one side maintains try to
maintain some relations with the West on
the other hand try to broker a deal
between Russia and the Ukraine when it
comes to the green for example or Global
Food security so all these new roles on
turkey's shoulder of course ultimately
effects is domestic
Dynamics domestic political Dynamics
domestic social cohesion and and through
this new equation a new new atmosphere
is emerging I think these political
alliances are partially due to these new
uh
Dimensions that turkey has been evolving
into in the past two decades
president erdogan's strong or stronger
than expected showing in the first round
really surprised a lot of the pollsters
who had predicted a different outcome
how did pollsters get this so wrong
that's the question which proves to be
extremely difficult to answer because
many posters had assumed uh yes the
people the Turkish electorate who pretty
much take into account how miserable the
economic situation we have at home and
how severe the migration problem is
already in today's turkey and also
thinking that the people are really fed
up that illegal authoritarianism or lack
of democracy are very much value
political rights and human rights but we
had clearly seen that the Turkish
electorate is much more homo
sociological rather than homo
economicals so identity based politics
uh focus on the national interests and
concerns over survival
allegiance to president had one
believing that okay he might have done
something bad in recent years but we
know that when he was given the
opportunity he defended things and many
things good in the past so he could
receive his success story then they have
given him another chance so I think such
kind of considerations uh have been
largely underestimated or ignored by I
mean the postal companies so this is
very much important and Target
I'm sorry I'm sorry to interrupt you we
are starting to run out of time we just
have about two minutes left I want to
ask you if Mr kalistarolu were to
Prevail in the runoff how difficult
would it be for him to unite his
Alliance after the election how tough
would that be I think that's the key
question even president erdogan is
underlying this point he was saying that
okay the nation allies consists of six
political parties as well as Earth bar
and supporters so reaching consensus
will be extremely difficult within this
Coalition and he has some point on that
and also
another difficult to might arise if we
have a president coming from one
particular allies but the parliament
coming from another Alliance so have
these two agencies will cooperate with
each other this is an extremely
difficult question to answer
will face a
increasingly difficult situation when he
was given the opportunity to build the
country because reaching consensus is
not a part of Turkish political culture
and ruling on consensus is very much
required in today's turkey but it will
prove it too difficult to
achieve because it is not in the DNA of
Turkish body politics let me put this
way all right we've run out of time so
we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to our
guest memet gelik and Tariq owuselu and
thanks also to Burak talgin he was with
us earlier and had to leave the program
early thanks to you also for watching
you can see the programming at any time
by visiting our website Al jazeera.com
and for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story you can
also join the conversation on Twitter
our handle is at AJ inside story from
Yamaha the whole team here bye for now
[Music]
thank you